o dia levantou sua voz a cama
dirige-se aos velho e olhar ao espelho
não reconhecem
é verdade que sally refletida
o que eu espero discuta sobre vocês quem
são o que acreditam e que realmente
valorizam na vida
o que os move a sair da cama todos os
dias valores é tudo aquilo que nós damos
importância na vida e crenças é aqui que
nós acreditamos
as crenças e valores conjugados definir
a nossa identidade
dizem que os sons que fazemos o que
fazemos
pra mim foi importante amor eu vou
procurar e sabor constantemente mas se
eu tiver por um lado a crença de que eu
não sou merecedora de ser amada mesmo
que esteja perante situações que possam
levar o amor que eu procuro não vou
identificar e vou autor sabotar mas vou
viver e fish continuamente e assim
valores e crenças determinam os nosso
estado está em nosso estado de espírito
em que vocês acreditam em que tu
valoriza as então vamos contar uma
história a minha história
era uma vez efe mas são todas as
histórias né gemia começou há 40 anos
atrás o meu nascimento quando a minha
mãe com apenas 70 anos de idade
oriunda de uma família humilde o tema
falar lá bateria cal não pula sido ter a
coragem de trazer ele colocar no mundo e
resgatar a minha história eu percebi que
ali aprendi inconscientemente meu
primeiro grande valor
a força ser isso aprendi com a minha mãe
mas a minha história com todas as
histórias da nossa história de vida de
cada um de vocês está aqui longa poderia
estar toda a tarde a quinta e deve
conversar sobre nós próprios e não seria
suficiente
os oito anos de idade eu conheci meu pai
bom eu já sabia que tinha um pai já o
sonhava muito tempo mas fogo quando
fisicamente a possibilidade de estar em
contato com ele e foi quando o pai mas
registou assumiu a sua paternidade e mas
subiu bateria aumento legalmente mas
acima de tudo emocionalmente e foi com
esse gesto do meu pai
os oito anos de idade que eu aprendi o
que é responsabilidade
qual foi a última vez que isto fosse
responsável quando é que assumisse a
responsabilidade da tua vida dos seus
atos mas vamos caminhar um pouco na
linha do tempo aos 22 anos de idade fui
abençoada pela dádiva da maternidade
fui mãe mãe do meu primeiro filho que
ontem fez 18 anos e com a maternidade
nash o amor o amor incondicional
aquilo que tudo suporta que o desafia
diariamente por exemplo pra frente não
tem princípio não tem fim e acho que
muitos de nós
ma e pais já experimentaram isso mas tu
já descobriu que o teu amor e humor
interior tumor por outra pessoa que está
magnífico certo
mas vamos aproximar muito mais da minha
história e ela traz um dos 36 anos de
idade
divorciada com três filhos dois deles
estão aqui é o meu amor incondicional
pelos meus três filhos e resolvi ir para
a índia já fazia meditação há mais de
dez anos pela necessidade espiritual
brahma kumaris e acreditava que ainda
podia ter um encontro comigo própria e
lá fui eu nessa jornada de forma muito
intuitiva impossível como é
caracterizado maior parte das vezes e na
índia
eu aprendi a importância de harmonização
pra mim é a organização mais importante
que o perdão para humanização e
reconciliação com a minha história com o
meu passado com a minha essência com a
minha idade interior e vocês meus
queridos permita que chamo meus novos
amigos já que conciliaram com vocês em
falta de perdão já se programaram para
vocês próprios com a nossa história e
toda essa trajetória
levo aqui ou agora após 40 anos de idade
o jes lembro a minha verdade a minha
liberdade interior e hoje aprendi com
todos que passaram pela minha vida e que
agregarão valor aquilo que eu sou hoje
o valor da autenticidade ser autêntico e
se é verdadeiro pra mim e pra que o que
é ser autêntico reflitam sobre isso
imagine que saiam desta palestra evando
volta ao espelho que você espera fraque
de hoje é importante perceber que para
mim a responsabilidade ou autenticidade
da harmonização só valores que trago pra
mim mas eu te perguntar o que é que é
importante na sua vida
se calhar justiça fiscaliza nada ganhar
dinheiro porque não se calhar foco
todos nós temos valores diferentes e
mesmo que os valores que nós temos que
são parecidos
nós damos importância e significado e
enfrenta eles e normalmente nisso é que
residem os conflitos porque eu quero
impor a minha verdade
os outros então vamos deixar aqui
algumas dicas que funcionaram comigo
a primeira é sai da zona de conforto à
risca e arriscar anda em contramão
todos podem seguir por um caminho mas se
tu acredita escutou caminha lado a
direita faz a tira outra dica que eu vou
dizer é que avaliem a vossa verdade
será que tudo que vocês acreditam e
pensa é realmente verdade quantas vezes
vocês dizem sim a gente apanha sejam
sinceros não precisam revelar que o meu
chefe não gosta nada de mim
será que o chefe não gosta daqui outro
teste desenvolver capacidades e
habilidades para entregar um em termos
de desempenho o melhor trabalho é menos
tempo e com maior qualidade avalia do
acordado continuamente faz acontecer de
eu viajar viaja quer aprender uma nova
língua escrita de amanhã a aprender que
a sua taxa básica e todos jogam pra
fazer isso e vou fazer
a faixa faz acontecer está nas suas mãos
e uma última dica que eu vou te dar é
signifiquem os vossos de valores
não esqueçam que o valor é tudo que nós
damos importância ea maior parte das
vezes é nos dado pelos vários agentes
sociais da nossa vida pelos meus pais
pelos nossos amigos familiares emprego
nas buscas nessa toda a essência aqui os
clubes cada
e por fim o e eu vos dizer e deixar com
esta frase pra mim é muito importante
será que tu estás a viver ea construir o
teu futuro com a base no teu passado com
base naquilo tudo acredita naquilo que
tu és hoje pode ser amigos crime tão
ligada
[Música]